he's like like we're not married we're
not acting as married and I said to him
then if that's where we are don't you
think that we should address that
publicly and he said no I don't want to
address it
I don't want to address it I don't want
that to be out there publicly because I
don't want that judgment and now Sister
Wives star Mary Brown's ready to tell
her side of the story we're still
learning how to have these conversations
and so yeah they do get hard sometimes
and real just days after Mary revealed
during the TLC series one-on-one special
that she and Cody are over she teased
her latest project a potential tell-all
yep that's Mary holding up a
leather-bound book with there's so much
more to the story written across it
that's the thing that I find you know
you just work through it and then you
get to a point that's good alongside the
pick Mary writes not all is always as it
seems quote we accept a version of a
story as truth because it fits the
narrative we've created or what we want
to believe it's not always about what
you're looking at but also where you're
looking from everyone has their own
experiences and their own truths Mary
ends her message with a cryptic tease
remember no matter how flat the pancake
is it always has two sides
ET has reached out to Mary and TLC for
comment we're so far into it now that we
know we can kind of predict
um how fans or not fans are going to
react and the comments that we're gonna
get and you know there's a lot of
positive and there's a lot of people
rooting for us and that is so good so if
Mary really is writing a memoir fans
hope she'll tackle major life events in
the pages including her 2015 catfish
Scandal which put a strain on her
relationship with Cody I thought I was
talking to a man online it wasn't a man
it was a woman
pretending to be a man and why Mary
stayed with Cody despite him pushing her
away I don't really consider myself
married to Mary if she wanted to move on
and marry another she wouldn't get an
argument with me I don't believe that we
can ever be functional
my strength is sticking around and
seeing if Cody would be willing to work
on a relationship so I leave that door
open
but I'm not pining away for it it's a
estranged marriage it's it's a marriage
that needs to work out some stuff and of
course the end of Cody and Mary's
30-plus year spiritual marriage he says
no I don't consider myself married to
Mary
like he just made the decision I've
never heard him say that to me yeah
improving yourself it's really hard to
look in the mirror sometimes and be like
huh what is it that I need to change and
improve on so that I can move forward
and it's good because sometimes things
aren't better but sometimes but then
they always do get better
[Music]
foreign
[Music]